welcome to this video playing the
national master luffy luffy whatever
from qatar okay cut the classical names
oh okay what am I playing it I can play
the Zurich variation again for change of
tried out cancelling and other stuff can
I can also start with you five like it's
flexible him
ya black ass sound very solid structure
with them healthy pieces good bishop on
c8 and what black man's to do is get in
F five it definitely will go for that
quickly here you need some some concrete
counter play um yeah well 96 is not a
big issue him I have fabric covered by
the bishop
Jake acid long it's not happening very
often in this opening or Bishop of
firefights both both good what I'm
trying to prove here like is that this
bishop on c3 is not such a great piece
trying to get this play on their farm
going maybe I should have taken you form
after nine takes after 90 x Bishop
cheeks okay let's not look so much at at
past position same just I need to play
him not lose on time so the night on f5
is Sam is covering the g7 pawn and the
bishop here now of course is active I
want Queenie eight would be nice nice to
get in Queenie eight possibly getting
the Queen's off
yeah if I get Queens exchanged I should
be okay with this week porn afford to
play against his bishop is is active but
still um yeah do I want want to give the
check and look on the e follow something
better yeah maybe here need to do this
anyway I guess
if i go here and then take f4 look for
look you want to give for i can pin Adam
I have I have Queenie for actually I do
have Queenie form rookie one Queenie for
as possible rook takes I take his rook
with check and Queen takes I mean yeah
it's pinned and Queen takes rook takes
should should keep the peace okay
shackling for this the sack sacrificial
idea trying to to do something with
rookie seven horses or something like
that okay how do I may be Queen f1 Queen
f1 to get the Queen's off he has a hard
time now to to to prevent that yeah yeah
well as strong as was probably a good
move if a exchanges playgroup e7 I
Brooke f72 to cover things between did
yeah okay
can take to take or not to take probably
taking check check
yeah still need some some patients to to
convert this yeah I don't really want
him to get rook e8 rook b8 whatever
maybe I can try to allow very little
counter blame or can maybe here maybe he
M to get gets in form
check
check yeah the king it was will help the
aged pawn to promote time warning
the rukon decide it's not resign
covering against checks on the G file
and I just go ping g2 and promoted
jago's was tricky position around around
him I think how to play on the FR should
be sufficient would like to be okay but
I think he probably can improve
somewhere here f form ya know I went for
the for the trade Sam may be okay 27s
may be more precise yeah that's true 27
and maybe night g6 mean to put pressure
on your form could be better but ok you
always want to get the night on this
great locating square you know h4 should
be very good for Wyatt really i thought
i have got to play with Queenie three
rookie aids but maybe that's not the
case h
yeah I thought Jack something like this
but he's very quickly I with age five
it's very dangerous computer is giving
white more than one pawn I try was
strong okay then ash then I must avoid
g6 and play Queen III first yeah it's
probably better a g6 I can play in any
case if necessary really and again age
for seems dangerous but he overlooked
this Queenie form I mean maybe he saw
the move but calculated something
something wrong me after that check yeah
this is this is very clean now the
Queen's get traded and then it's over
okay thanks for watching